most history videos are about the past
but this one's different this is a
history video about the
future a future of the Myriad possible
versions of the 21st century this is a
future in which we win we overcome the
climate
crisis this is far from a best case
scenario if such a thing exists it's not
the most likely scenario but it is a
possible future a future in which in the
year 2100 the intergovernmental panel on
climate change publishes a special
report on climate change in it authors
from around the world detail how global
average temperatures have stabilized how
the concentration of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere peaked and has slowly
Fallen detailing the immense impacts of
anthropogenic climate change over the
past Century on humans and the natural
world and the challenges that will
Define the 22nd century for both
but that report also details the path
not taken the 21st century with its
soaring temperatures and plagues and
floods as it would have been if a
different path had been chosen in the
critical year of
[Music]
let's provide some historical context
the first few Decades of the 21st
century continue the trends of the late
20th century observations of the Earth's
system made it extremely clear that the
climate was changing carbon dioxide was
building up in the atmosphere
overwhelmingly from burning fossil fuels
coal gas and oil scientists use computer
models economic forecasts and arguments
from the historical record to show that
this would have significant impacts
global average temperatures would climb
extreme weather events would become more
extreme and more frequent societies
would become poorer and more prone to
sudden breakages millions of species
around the world would face increased
pressure or outright Extinction these
changes would occur the scientists
warned at a pace that had no historic
parallel it would be disastrous to
continue down the path chosen at the
start of the century instead the world
should limit warming to less than 2° C
ideally less than 1 and 1 12° the more
warming the world experienced Above This
level the more likely it became that the
world would pass a Tipping Point in
which climatic changes would intensify
possibly triggering more tipping points
and warming the world not by a few
degrees but as many as a dozen the
scientists were clear there was no
Silver Bullet to achieving this but that
there would be Myriad Solutions some
large some small however the largest by
far was reducing consumption of the
fossil fuels that pumped CO2 into the
atmosphere to keep warming below
dangerous levels they stressed the world
needed to remove its dependence on coal
oil and gas the world was sluggish to
respond in the first Decades of the 21st
century as in the late 20th century
limited action took place to transition
away from fossil fuels use of renewable
electricity generation in particular
solar began to take off but other
sectors in particular heating transport
and agriculture barely shifted this was
because at least in part also continuing
a trend from the late 20th century
powerful multinational companies that
produced and sold fossil fuels did
everything they could to prevent And
Delay the transition away from said
fuels in some cases this action was
overt such as paying politicians to
block legislation and financing public
information campaigns to cast doubt on
climate science or more subtle such as
paying for Aster Turf campaigns to
change public perception of local energy
projects notably Exxon later Exxon
Mobile deliberately blocked publication
of research that indicated their
company's products were altering the
earth's climate they knew this fact and
chose to ignore it later analysis would
estimate that these corporate actions
would delay the peak of global emissions
by two decades causing an estimated 35
million excess deaths and leading to the
controversial Acra Trials of 2073
but that's a point for
later let's pick up the story in the
2020s in 2023 a strong El Nino phase
began raising temperatures in the
Pacific Ocean and so the world average
with a large natural temperature anomaly
on top of the anthropogenic warming
caused since the Industrial Revolution
2023 became the warmest year on record
by quite some distance before 2024 beat
that same record
alongside these soaring temperatures
extreme weather events became noticeably
more intense flooding in Libya heat
waves in Europe droughts in China and
India around now the science of
attribution became more and more
concrete scientists were able to say
with greater certainty that heat waves
and droughts and eventually other
phenomena like floods were made more
likely by climate change and quantify
how much more damaging they were because
of it this science was the center of
media attention in 2028 when Miami was
hit by Category 5 hurricane Carl and
then 3 weeks later from the other
direction by Category 5 hurricane Lisa
Disaster Response was completely
overwhelmed able to cope with one
hurricane but utterly ill equipped to
deal with the new possibility of
clustered extreme events attribution
analysis indicated that the $300 billion
cost of the store STS would have been
orders of magnitude lower in a world
without climate change if the double
storm event could have happened at all
all around the world in the 2020s
extreme events were made more intense
and more frequent by climate change and
as a moderate Alo phase began again 2029
took the record for the warmest year but
the world did not watch these disasters
unfold and the temperatures rise Higher
and Higher and simply do nothing public
support for decarbonization the process
of reducing Global carbon emissions
became more widespread enshrined in
international law in fact with the Paris
agreement of 2015 which committed 194
signatur Nations to reducing carbon
emissions with the goal of keeping
global warming below 2° C A lot of these
successes came down to the increasingly
vocal climate activist movement
championed initially by scientists and
later organized groups such as
Extinction rebellion and Fridays for
future as the decade wore on in larger
and larger and more disruptive peaceful
protests people demanded change no new
coal power plants no more subsidies for
fossil fuel extraction a price on carbon
though some activists became more and
more radical directly targeting the
infrastructure of the root cause of the
climate crisis the fossil fuel industry
pipelines and refineries were first the
focus of siins then bombings much later
analysis would debate the impact these
radical actions had on climate action
and whether they in fact delayed
stabilizing global temperatures by
turning people against
decarbonization regardless the world was
changing and becoming less carbon
intense much of this change came from
National governments policies were
enacted that required improvements to
Energy Efficiency incentives were given
to individuals transitioning from the
use of fossil fuels to electrified
systems such as heat pumps and electric
cars there were Landmark pieces of
legislation such as the European climate
law of 2020 1 and the American inflation
reduction Act of 2022 these pieces of
legislation were derided by many as not
going far enough which of course turned
out to be true but they did still result
in meaningful change in particular
thanks to National Target setting the
global electricity supply of the 2020s
quite rapidly transitioned away from
fossil fuels with solar photovoltaics
becoming the largest source of Power by
installed capacity in 2027 to keep up
with the everg growing demand for the
raw materials for new solar panels and
lithium ion batteries Mining and
refining operations expanded
particularly in Africa foreign Capital
overwhelmingly from China funded new
mines for Cobalt ctan lithium and other
minerals in fact as the 2030s began
China's Ambitions in Africa were very
plain huge quantities of money and
trained Personnel were invested in the
continent as part of the expanded belt
and Road scheme this was partly to
cement China's Monopoly on the supply of
the new fundamental resources of the
decarbonized global economy and partly
to expand its geopolitical influence
Chinese nuclear reactor technology was
exported to African leaders these
leaders seeing population projections of
huge growth and densely packed cities
needed rapid expansion of their
electrical grids and readily accepted
China had influence all over the
continent the Sino African nuclear
Consortium over the coming decades
significantly reduced the carbon
intensity of new Urban grids and even
coordinated the disposal of the nuclear
waste produced by these new reactors
dumping it in an unfashionable part of
Somalia for which the Somalian
government was somewhat compensated
China became the dominant force in
global geopolitics somewhere around here
depending on which author you believe
surpassing the increasingly militaristic
United States and as leadership changed
China became less confrontational and
opened up to the world meanwhile the
other side of the Himalayas the other
population be off of India was rising in
influence and becoming more closed off
and shifting towards a single party
State the BJP consolidating power
together China and India moving in
rather different directions represented
almost 40% of all humans on Earth and so
their efforts to decouple economic
growth from emitting carbon into the
atmosphere would be crucial fortunately
they were making great progress in doing
so China undeniably got a head start on
India leading a colossal push in solar
energy in the 2010s and 2020s and its
carbon emissions peaking in
2027 India didn't achieve Peak emissions
until the 2040s for the same reason that
China's emissions didn't Peak even
sooner
coal much as China and India invested
heavily in solar technology for the
first half of the 21st century their
economies ran on coal the oldest and
most polluting of all fossil fuels
continuing to build new coal Farm power
plants even into the 2040s it was only
when under pressure from widespread
activism the International Community
demanded the phase out of coal by 2050
threatening a carbon export tariff that
the fuel was finally retired to the
history books a process accelerated
needless to say by the events of
2044 it should be pointed out of course
that the International Community
benefited enormously from the cheap
electricity coal provided in
manufacturing their goods for import
from China and India and in a very real
sense the world economy not just China
and India's had run on coal up to this
point regardless much was made of how
these two nations were quote holding the
world back as clustered extreme events
like hurricanes Carl and Lisa and the
droughts across South America in 2033
became more common China and India both
spent the 203s rolling out
record-breaking quantities of renewable
energy through a combination of Chinese
nuclear Tech technology hydroelectric
and a surprising number of Next
Generation geothermal power plants they
replaced the Bedrock of their and thus
the world's electricity Supply in 2034
the same year that China began opening
up to the world attention was on the
oceans and it was a year of
contrasts on the one hand Landmark legal
protections were enacted preserving for
the first time more than 50% of the
ocean from exploitation plastic waste
and chemical pollution at least on paper
conservation groups hailed the news
saying it would be pivotal in at least a
resting and alarming decline in global
fish stocks and oceanic
biodiversity but it would prove too late
for the world's tropical
corals that year the Great Barrier Reef
off the coast of Australia underwent the
single largest bleaching event the world
had ever seen rising ocean acidity
combined with an oceanic Heat Wave
resulted in the severe bleaching of 86%
of all Corals in The Reef it was
estimated that the Great Barrier Reef
had lost 34 of all its corals since
1995 and the phenomenon was not limited
to Australian Waters by 2034 globally
50% of all corals the most biodiverse
environment in the oceans had gone
extinct their loss threatened a Tipping
Point a Tipping Point in climate terms
is a set of conditions Beyond which
changes in a part of the climate system
become self-perpetuating those changes
can lead to abrupt irreversible and
dangerous impacts Coral loss was a
regional Tipping Point once Coral
populations dropped below a certain
level they might be locked into a doom
spiral unable to return to their
previous populations this would have
devastating impacts on the local marine
food web and temperature and changes in
The Wider Marine nutrient and carbon
Cycles but in the 2020s scientists
identified eight Global tipping points
if one of these tipping points were to
be reached the impact would be
significant worldwide and potentially
enormous regionally for example if the
Atlantic meridianal overturning
circulation a deep conveyor belt of heat
in the Atlantic Ocean were to collapse
the planet would cool by up to half a de
C but Europe specifically could cool by
as much as
10° a return to Ice Age
conditions these tipping points would be
triggered at certain levels of global
warming exactly how much warming
scientists in the 2020s did not know but
they could provide a range of
temperatures and their best guess of
where in that range The Tipping Point
would be reached these best guesses
ranged from 1 and 1/2 de of warming to 7
and 1/2 de of warming as it stood in the
2020 s and 2030s the expected trajectory
of the 21st century could trigger some
of these tipping points and if that
happened their additional warming could
trigger a Cascade effect Tipping Point
after tipping point being reached and
the global climate rendered increasingly
unrecognizable it was for this reason
that scientists and activists were so
vocal about keeping global warming below
1 and a 12° c it was the best bet to
avoid hitting any of these Global
tipping points
as it turned out however the loss of
tropical corals was not the only Tipping
Point reached in the
2030s bombshell analysis in 2035
indicated that the Greenland ice sheet
was in the early stages of collapse
sooner than expected if total collapse
occurred additional sea level rise
solely from the Greenland ice sheet
could be 2 and A2 m in the case of a
Cascade up to seven additional M over a
few centuries a scenario described by
one of the authors of the analysis as
game
over but the analysis stressed this was
not inevitable if global temperatures
could be stabilized and brought down to
pre-industrial levels within a century
or two total collapse could be avoided
and while temperature records continued
to be broken Global decarbonization was
certainly headed in the right direction
electrical grids were becoming less
carbon intense with massive investment
in new grids and Storage roll out of
solar and wind and the commissioning of
new geothermal and more controversially
outside of Asia nuclear plants but the
world wasn't just putting less carbon
into the atmosphere it was also starting
to draw down more carbon from it in some
cases this was done deliberately such as
in direct air capture plants powered by
renewable electricity these did next to
nothing having such a small effect as to
be statistically insignificant still
they were deemed promising for the
future and had billions invested in them
by large corporations aiming for Net
Zero without actually reducing their
emissions by the end of the century they
would contribute perhaps 5% of all
anthropogenic carbon draw down more
effective were rewilding efforts
restoring lost habitats and in
particular replanting diverse species of
trees in Lost Woodlands but an
unintentional quite significant carbon
sink came from cities in an attempt to
mitigate Rising temperatures provide
shade and beautify the increasingly
dense environment enironment City
governments planted trees in streets in
tree corridors in Parks our forestation
became a form of civic pride cities
competing to plant the most trees and
reap the benefits of cooler fresher Air
One entire sector that underwent a
transformation in the 2030s to reduce
its carbon emissions was transport at
the start of the century road vehicles
for both passengers and Freight were the
largest contributors to Global carbon
emissions from transport almost entirely
relying on burning hydrocarbon in
internal combustion engines beginning in
the 2010s however these vehicles were
gradually replaced with electric
vehicles slowly at first but by the late
2030s electric cars and then light Goods
vehicles and finally trucks began to
dominate with bans on new internal
combustion engine vehicles coming into
effect in many countries also reducing
emissions from road vehicles however was
an explosive investment in the late
2020s in high-speed International Rail
and specifically connections between
High-Speed Rail networks this was
spurred in part by the coronavirus
pandemic of 2020 which accelerated the
move of service sector employees working
from home allowing them to live further
from their employment and thus
increasing the distances they would
travel when they did travel to work
being the center of such service sector
jobs Europe North America and
particularly Asia saw huge
infrastructure upgrades allowing for
fast electrified inter city travel in
some cases especially when paired with
improved Urban public transport as was
the case in European cities this s
reduced dependency on cars in others
such as North American cities it reduced
dependency on planes the longdistance
transport of people and Freights by
planes and ships had remained stubbornly
difficult to decarbonize apart from
efficiency improvements until
2037 it was in this year that so-called
sustainable Aviation fuels made from
biological sources like corn and refined
with low carbon electricity became cost
competitive with traditional fuels like
kerosene for the first time this marked
the beginning of a multi- decadal
reduction in the environmental impact of
flying with shipping following just
behind partly due to the successful
decarbonization process of the transport
sector Global carbon emissions hit an
historic milestone in
2035 that year the world released
49.2 gigatons of carbon dioxide
equivalent the most it would ever emit
in one year 2035 was Peak carbon
emissions from here though unevenly net
carbon emissions would fall throughout
the century overwhelmingly due to the
reduction in emissions from shifting
away from fossil fuels this was the
cause for huge celebrations with many
commentators and politicians hailing
that the tide has turned or that the
climate crisis has been tackled PE
commissions parties were hosted all over
the world by generation of people told
that their future would be defined by
ever increasing emissions and ever
increasing damage to to the natural
world climate activism was no longer
about the future it was about the
present that year the eer nuclear fusion
reactor fired up in France and almost
made it to net positive energy
production more energy came out of the
fusion reaction than was put in if you
ignored losses and inefficiencies clean
near Infinite Energy was now just surely
decades away with the next technical
demonstration it really seemed like
cause for celebration the world had done
it the path to Net Zero was now
inevitable but these celebrations were
premature carbon was still building up
in the atmosphere though more slowly
than before and the second half of the
decade saw the effects of the resulting
climate change begin to
bite 2036 saw first heat wve conditions
and then huge downpours in Europe and
Central Asia the sunbaked Earth became
impermeable and the Rain Led to wide
spread flash flooding vast areas were
covered with water and these flood
waters then acted as perfect incubators
for mosquitoes due to changing
temperature and precipitation patterns
mosquitoes had become more and more
widespread outside the tropics and in
the case of 2036 such midlatitude
mosquitoes led to an outbreak of West
Nile virus that killed 5,000 people by
the mid-century such outbreaks of
previously tropical diseases would occur
several times a decade in the mid
latitudes with death tolls each year
ranging from the high hundreds to the
low tens of thousands attribution
analysis indicated that these outbreaks
were all made vastly more likely by
climate change water was the root cause
of much of what was to come either too
much or too little in Europe there was
too much in Egypt there was too little
and that was because of the g d the
grand Ethiopian Renaissance Dam this was
the largest hydroelectric plant in
Africa supplying almost all of
Ethiopia's electricity needs doing so
however required restriction of the flow
of the Blue Nile into Egypt and when due
to shifting precipitation patterns in
2036 the Reigns failed as they did in
2037 and 2038 in order to maintain power
generation Ethiopia slowed the flow of
the Nile to a relative trickle
throughout These Years Egypt and Sudan
voiced their protests the Nile was after
all the only freshwater source for the
majority of Egypt and so vital for
sanitation and agriculture negotiations
took place with Ethiopia who said their
energy security was Paramount Egypt
escalated to the African Union than the
United Nations words escalated Egypt
warned that its people would start dying
if the Reigns failed again to which
Ethiopia said if the rains fail the
region will need a large supply of
electricity for desalination more than
ever ever eventually threats were made
ignored and then carried out Egypt sent
fighter jets to air strike the dam and
renew the supply of the Nile by force
The Fallout was immense conflict quickly
escalated as both countries mobilized
troops near the border and neighboring
countries and indeed the International
Community were forced to take sides
despite a lack of orders skirmishes took
place between infantry and armored
fighting vehicles at the border as heat
scorched tensions boiled over at the
last minute desperate negotiations
mediated by China anxious to avoid
disruption of its supply of lithium
avoided allout war but Regional
stability was in tatters as it was
elsewhere in Saudi Arabia filling a
power vacuum left by the increasingly
disinterested United States having
largely weaned itself off oil Iranian
funded groups gain ground in the Sahel
in the late 2030s partly driven by crop
failures and partly by high excess
mortality caused by heat stress
overwhelming the Healthcare Systems
multiple States including bikina Faso
Chad Mali and nier underwent coup or
attempted coups ner split into
modern-day ner and the agadez sultanate
and then it was 2040 and the world hit a
grim Milestone amid clustered extreme
events and spreading tropical diseases
Mass migration and drought in 2040 the
global average temperature anomaly over
the previous 5 years was officially
confirmed as
1.5°
celius doubtlessly helped by a
persistent alino phase in the Pacific
Ocean the world still stood face to face
with a grim reality of its own making
just 5 years after carbon emissions had
peaked the effort to limit warming to
1.5° was over activists had lost the
fight the trajectory forwards and just
how much more warming we would
experience was uncertain and much hinged
on the crucial decade that was to come
with every tenth of a degree of
additional warming the world was more
likely to trigger more tipping points
with emissions declining as they were at
the start of the decade despite Promises
by politicians over the past 30 years
total cumulative carbon emissions would
lead to anthropogenic global warming
stabilizing around the turn of the
century at 2.3 de as you can see this
would likely result in the total
collapse of the West Antarctic ice sheet
the Greenland ice sheet the Atlantic
subpolar Gaia as well as several
Regional tipping points such as the loss
of all Mountain glaciers abrupt Thor of
the Boreal permafrost and the loss of
ice in the barren sea the combined
effect of these tipping points on
further warming was uncertain sea level
rise by the end of the century was
expected to be 70 CM but it would not
stop there by the end of The Next
Century sea levels were expected to have
risen by 2 and A2 M this would submerge
land home in 2040 to to over a billion
people the world stood on a
precipice as we now know of course this
trajectory did not happen but in 2040
there was a very real sense of Despair
over the past few decades climate
related mental health conditions had
become more and more common people did
not feel one and a half degrees warmer
but they felt the extremes they felt the
weekl long heat waves the spikes in
prices of food after droughts The Sting
of once tropical diseases overwhelming
healthc Care Centers climate anxiety was
recognized as a condition in the 2010s
and by 2040 it had become something of
an epidemic people were having fewer
children with climate anxiety being
cited as the most common reason
throughout the 2020s and 2030s
increasing numbers of notes left behind
by people who took their own lives
referenced the climate in the 2040s this
climate despair was commonplace and the
subject of multiple Public Health
inquiries and looking at the world these
people left behind it wasn't hard to see
why across almost every continent
political instability was Rising extreme
weather events were becoming more common
and more intense threatening agriculture
drinking water supplies and cities
themselves diseases previously confined
to the tropics were becoming more and
more common and as the world continued
to burn fossil fuels for electricity and
Industry parate matter from incomplete
combustion killed Millions each year
largely in the huge cities of Africa and
Asia climate refugees fearing both
political unrest and uninhabitable
conditions poured across National
borders first in their thousands then in
their hundreds of thousands then in
their Millions further straining
political discourse every few years a
country would swing to the hard right
and declare a Hardline stance on
immigrants pushing ever growing
vulnerable groups to the edges of
society
India did this in 2041 closing and
fortifying the border to Bangladesh
increasingly under pressure from rising
sea levels with neighborhoods of Dhaka
being abandoned India's government
cracked down even on internal migration
leading to ever Rising political tension
the natural world was clearly being
depleted with species going extinct at a
rate approximately 5,000 times greater
than the natural Extinction rate unique
bird song disappeared from forests never
to be heard again the entire ecosystems
underwent population collapse as
keystone species went extinct in a
further decline in 2043 it was announced
that 75% of all corals had gone extinct
their continued existence by 2100 was in
severe doubt and then that same year
open War erupted in Central
Asia in the 1920s Soviet authorities
Drew new arbitrary borders for the
constituent republics of usbekistan
kyrgistan and Tajikistan these borders
did not account for ethnic economic or
geographical differences and were
frankly a complete mess since the fall
of the Soviet Union and Independence for
these countries in 1991 the borders have
been a source of conflict of other
increasing importance was the fagana
valley this fertile Valley supplied
water for agriculture and drinking and
was of vital importance to the three
countries that shared clumb borders
within it those borders were the Tinder
and the water supply the spark for the
war of
2043 you see far to the southeast over
The Late 20th century the ARL sea wants
the fourth largest lake in the world
dried out due to the rivers that
supplied it being diverted for
agriculture where once was the ARL sea
is now the aralon desert dust from the
newly formed desert was blown onto
Mountain glaciers the p and the tianan
that fed the fagana valley and this dust
lowered the reflectivity of the glaciers
which combined with rapidly Rising
temperatures in the mountains led to
hugely accelerated melt of the glaciers
suddenly the water supply precariously
shared between the three countries was
in Jeopardy and there simply wasn't
enough to go around in 20143 in a turn
of events almost entirely caused by the
twin environmental disasters of climate
change and heavy-handed agriculture
usbekistan struck first and declared war
on both kyrgistan and Tajikistan
occupying the fagana valley thanks to
the overwhelming military Advantage this
water conflict raged actively for 6
weeks and passively for six years with
casualties in the tens of thousands it
was the first true water War but not the
last but suddenly then it was
2044 and the ACT axle of History was
about to turn you may have noticed that
a key group of actors have thus far been
missing from this history we've spoken
about how cumulative emissions of carbon
dioxide were altering the atmosphere and
causing the world to on average warm
we've also spoken about how the dominant
sources of these emissions were fossil
fuels gas coal and oil so what in the
first half of the 21st century when the
environmental harm of their industry was
becoming more and more obvious were the
companies that extracted and refined
those fossil fuels doing well for the
most part extracting and refining even
more fossil fuels despite the overtures
of national governments in conferences
such as Paris in 2015 and Lagos in 2027
fossil fuel extraction ramped up through
the first quarter of the century coal in
India so-called natural gas in the
United States oil in Saudi Arabia and
all of this was supported by extensive
subsidies for the industry representing
fully 7% of global GDP in
2023 after all if the system ain't broke
and is generating profit don't fix it
yet we've already heard that the
transport and particularly electricity
sectors were successfully decarbonizing
by the 2040s demand for fossil fuels
across the board was decreasing lowcar
carbon Alternatives which were cheaper
per unit of energy supplied became
available and practical in more and more
settings some fossil fuel producers were
not blind to this while all maintain
publicly that we take the climate crisis
very seriously and we have been
investing in renewable energy
alternatives for the majority of
companies these were mere words that
well maybe true in some cases had no
practical impact companies such as Royal
Dutch Shell aramco and Exon Mobile had
tied their corporate identities to oil
and if they were changing their business
model at all were doing so very slowly
investments in green hydrogen produced
by by electrolysis using cheap solar
energy and transported by existing
infrastructure were slow as were
investments in new electrical grids
containing some new renewable generation
but also locking in further use of
fossil fuels BP was one of a handful of
fossil fuel producers to put rhetoric
into action as a chief executive put it
candidly in 2031 we see ourselves as an
energy company not specifically a fossil
fuel company sure that's the historic
Source but at the end of the day our
contracts are to supply x amount of
power to the grid of country y for Z
years we will do that in the cheapest
way we can regardless of source in 2019
BP spent 3% of its capital expenditure
on transitional Energy Products in 2022
that number was 30% and in 2028
90% the fact was renewable sources of
energy were already cheaper than coal
oil and gas BP saw the opportunity to
have first mover advantage and
ultimately make a lot of money still
despite significant investments in green
hydrogen and sustainable Aviation fuels
their business model was largely based
on fossil fuels and so as the 2020s
turned into the 2030s their margins were
squeezed by the coming crisis you see
production of fossil fuels had been
ramped up across the industry having bet
that Renewables uptake would be slower
than it proved to be however in order to
remain cost competitive with those cheap
renewable energy sources fosto fuel
companies were forced to sell their
products at lower and lower prices those
prices were artificially lowered further
by a desire to offload their assets with
negative
Futures production was high and price
was dropping like a stone producers
profits started to Tumble having
somewhat Diversified by the 2030s BP and
a handful of other companies were more
insulated from this than many of their
competitors who had realized the danger
and began shifting to Renewables but too
late in the early 2030s some small
producers started going out of business
by the late 2030s some mediumsized
producers went bust snapped up by larger
companies but the bankruptcies hit their
peak in
2044 and the industry would never be the
same
again this was the year the Year where
decades long processes came to a
conclusion the fulcrum around which the
future pivoted the year started with the
aftermath of the fagana valley War
reverberating around the world but as
spring turned to Summer the eyes of the
world turned further north much further
north to the Arctic because this summer
2044 after Decades of decline satellites
confirmed that the Arctic was entirely
free of sea ice for the first time in
human history an entire ecosystem had
been irrevocably damaged the resulting
change in Planet AR albo in summer was
expected to accelerate warming further
the world SE from space now looked very
different thanks to climate change but
the news did not stop there at the other
end of the world in ustal Winter
scientists announced that the West
Antarctic ice sheet long in Decline and
its loss considered inevitable had
started rapidly deteriorating the
previous summer The Tipping Point had
been reached and faster than expected
the entire ice sheet was falling apart
sea level rise estimates were revised
upwards again threatening hundreds of
millions of people the chological
systems on Earth glaciers sea ice ice
sheets were in their death
throws droughts and heat waves occurred
yearly ecosystems were disappearing
refugees were building up on National
borders the world was looking more and
more
unrecognizable people looked to the
Future and were were scared climate
activists reached their peak of
radicalization gas pipelines oil
refineries coal mines even corporate
headquarters were the targets for
physical assaults enormous climate
marches demanded that governments enter
crisis mode controversial negotiations
around the use of geoengineering dimming
the Sun by injecting sulfur dioxide into
the stratosphere founded at the United
Nations and it was against all of this
that in the summer of
2044 the fossil fuel industry collapsed
at first it was a few producers the
typical rate for the previous decade but
then the big dominoes started to fall
arono then shell then in a Cascade total
energies Petrina and more all failures
caused by the ever lowering price of oil
and gas and this summer the removal of
billions of dollars of capital by
investors who either saw the ship
sinking or finally grew a conscience the
only analogy of scale that could be
drawn was the financial crash of 2008
and the cascading collapse of the
financial sector but far far bigger like
2008 these major fossil fuel producers
thought that they were too big to fail
bailouts must come from National
governments or the world energy Market
would be thrown into chaos surely the
bailouts would
come and here the world's governments
and financial ministers stood at the
turning point the old guard of the
energy industry had come cap in hand
with modest bailouts of a few trillion
dollars that would of course eventually
mostly be repaid the Giants of coal oil
and gas could turn the Taps back on keep
the gas flowing and keep the global
economy stable by giving a bailout these
companies could invest in new sources of
energy and while the economy would
require the extraction of fossil fuels
for a few more decades eventually the
energy Majors would be ready for the
transition I doing so would prolong the
use of fossil fuels and keep emissions
high for a little while but it would be
worth it to ensure shareholder profits
and of course
stability within governments around the
world politicians that were bankrolled
by these energy Majors were vocal in
their support for such bailouts and in
some Petro States like Kuwait and the
UAE nationalized energy companies
received the
bailout but most governments said
no there were vast vast crowds outside
every Parliament and state house and
legislature on earth look at what is
happening they said look at the Arctic
look at the war in the fagana valley
look at the Great Barrier Reef how much
more do we have to lose before you
change our course by this point climate
activism had permeated every level of
society it was no longer a distinct
movement but in meshed within gender
activism local environmental groups
social justice groups education groups
the list went on but in the end as would
emerge in interviews conducted years
later as part of the pullit a prize
winning enough the turning point for the
majority of government officials was
their children the officials were of a
generation brought up as the climate
crisis became more apparent but they
would not be around to see the year 2100
they would not be around to see the
world that scientists projected but
their children would as one British
Finance Minister put it I looked into my
daughter's eyes and imagined what she
would see when she was my age how could
I live with myself for inflicting that
future upon
her bailouts were denied companies
folded the global economy went into
turmoil not seen since the AI bubble of
2026 or the pandemic of 2020 those
companies that did receive bailouts
almost all failed within 3 years
plunging Petra States like the UAE into
even deeper crisis nationalized
companies were stri of their assets and
remade into modern energy companies
those that had significantly Diversified
fared better with BP taking enormous
losses but still operating and just
barely making profits even in the worst
of the crisis another notable Survivor
was Exxon Mobile who through corporate
ruthlessness and ferocious lobbying of
the American government was able to
secure a Lifeline battered and bruised
they continued extracting oil to fuel
the dwindling Aviation and shipping
sectors but these companies were a thing
of the past while public opinion had
finally turned against fossil fuels the
simple fact was that basic economics had
a long time previously burning
hydrocarbons was in the majority of
cases simply not cost competitive with
other sources of energy especially solar
which had only become cheaper and
cheaper with each passing decade with
the immense financial support of
governments removed having been locked
into such support for a century or more
sustained by extensive lobbying the
industry started fading away assets that
had been valued at billions of dollars
were left in the ground the cost of
extracting them considered too high both
financially and environmentally even the
once enormous Plastic industry could not
sustain the sector having become less
dependent on oil and producing far lower
quantities after the bands on single-use
Plastics of the 2030s while the world
still needed refined crude oil for some
applications the energy Market was no
longer beholden to Fuels of the past
to
fossils by 2100 the business of fossil
fuel extraction and refinement was worth
less than 1% of its value a century
before in 2044 those funds previously
used to support the fossil field
industry were now repurposed refusing
the bailouts was not enough the public
demanded the vast diverse climate
activism movement now an avalanche of
Voters wanted Action Now government
scrambled for an easy target and found
it in methane methane emissions had been
the target for reductions in the
previous two decades but with limited
success now repurpose money was poured
into reforming waste disposal
dismantling natural gas infrastructure
and of course decarbonizing agriculture
largely through reducing consumption of
meat methane emissions plummeted over
the rest of the decade making a
significant dent in global carbon
emissions those governments that did not
deliver these victories were simply
ejected from office in Landslide
victories for climate Cent parties the
world more connected than ever before
was gripped by a kind of green wartime
spirit this decade would play host to
the largest most coordinated
environmental movement ever seen it
speed astonished veteran campaigners
used to glacial progress in 2045 another
notable victory was won for the climate
movement as a moratorium on
deforestation in the Amazon was agreed
safeguarding the largest most diverse
rainforest on Earth and an enormous
carbon sink by 50 it was also announced
that the cement and Steel Industries had
both been effectively decarbonized
making cement chemically requires the
release of carbon dioxide and both
cement and steel require extremely high
energy densities to manufacture their
products while the former benefited from
the rapid expansion of carbon capture at
source Technologies both were
effectively retrofitted to use green
hydrogen produced using African and
Australian Sunshine the corporate
survivors of the collapse of 2044 were
able to carve out a new Niche for
themselves here elsewhere in enormous
quantities of capital were invested in
renewable energy generation seen as the
new no-brainer investment by accountants
that would have previously CED all
producers or Commodities Traders as the
2040s turned into the 2050s the carbon
intensity of the global electrical grid
NOS dived as the Investments of the
previous few decades truly made
themselves known vast new solar and wind
farms covered the landscape bringing
electrification to the last few regions
of the world that had previously been in
the dark elsewhere GE geothermal and
hydroelectric plants powered mediumsized
cities and in some areas nuclear plants
that have began Construction in the
2030s finally came online and powered
evergrowing
metropolises in 2051 the European Union
announced that it had finally reached
carbon neutrality putting no more carbon
into the atmosphere than it removed
through expanded forests and agriculture
a few years later in 2053 the United
States announced hitting the same
Milestone the final piece of the puzzle
had been Aviation which despite
expansion of High-Speed Rail remained
vital to the American economy as the
price of sustainable Aviation fuels
continued to decline so too did the net
impact of flying with the announcement
Exxon Mobile stock tied in no small part
to Aviation fell
significantly there was still however a
climate crisis happening and it was not
all good news minor water wars and
skirmishes took place in Africa South
America and Central Asia in 2054 the
prospect of War loomed very very large
and very real in the Himalayas as
Mountain glacial systems continued to
deteriorate in Tibet both China and
India saw their water supplies being
threatened in a pattern that had become
all too familiar to geopolitical
analysts first there was an escalation
of words then a buildup of troops near
the border militaries were placed on
high alert offers of mediation Talks by
the United States were firmly rebuffed
the escalated standoff lasted for 9
months until eventually
merely China blinked tensions remained
but troops were placed on Lower alert at
least for the time being in 2100 of
course the issue of Tibet water India
and China remains an unresolved problem
the stability of the Middle East was
also thrown into doubt as in 2053 an
Iranian backed coup took over in Saudi
Arabia the region was set for decades of
unrest as Iran and Shia Islam continued
to expand its influence through a number
of small small states that were in the
process of rebuilding through
transitioning to solar based economies
elsewhere the slow creeping Menace of
sea level rise had claimed its early
victims small settlements and farmland
were lost sporadically at first and then
as the decade wore on more and more
frequently in 2058 after more than a
decade of slow transition the capital of
Indonesia was forly relocated to n
santara with the old capital of Jakarta
abandoned to the wave
in the United States apart from a few
enclaves maintained by eccentric
billionaires the Tampa Bay Area was also
abandoned around the same time the State
of Florida and its unique culture were
visibly sinking below sea
level the world did not see these
developments and despair however by the
end of the middle decade of the 21st
century a new generation was firmly in
charge in management and government
positions the guard had changed to those
who had grown up with the climate crisis
a constant factor in their lives a
problem that they knew they had to rise
to the challenge of the momentum of
change was maintained with further
upgrades to the stability storage and
interconnectivity of electrical grids
around the world our forestation
planting lots of trees largely where
they had been previously cut down became
the buzzword efforts by the dwindling
fossil fuel business to tie government
decarbonization policy to direct air
carbon capture and storage were rebu
those schemes with bio energy with
carbon capture and storage growing crops
burning them to generate electricity and
then capturing and storing the carbon in
the ground were more effective the
global loss and damage fund financed
several such projects to assist with the
economic development of southern Africa
in 2059 scientists delivered some good
news after intense observations and no
small amount of subglacial modeling they
revised their estimates of the collapse
of the Greenland ice sheet while melt
was still significant it was now
believed that the ice sheet was more
stable than previously feared The
Tipping Point had not quite been reached
total collapse was not inevitable and
could be avoided if temperatures came
down fast enough in 2060 scientists
delivered even better news the world was
estimated to have reached Net Zero
carbon dioxide emissions China had
reached Net Zero in 2055 and India in
2059 between the net negative emissions
of other power blocks over the past
decade or so which had become not
insignificant the residual emissions of
the rest of the world had been balanced
out at least for carbon dioxide a few
smaller greenhouse gases notably methane
remained to be entirely
balanced then in 2063 the big
announcement came thanks to a fortunate
extended linia phase in the Pacific
Ocean uptake of carbon from the
atmosphere by the biosphere had been
larger than expected for a few years and
as a result concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere had peaked at
515 parts per million almost double what
it was before the Industrial Revolution
a 40% increase since the start of the
century but starting in 2063 that number
would begin to slowly
fall celebrations erupted around the
world activists born around the turn of
the century who had fought for this
outcome for their entire lives were
overcome with emotion the Eurovision
song contest that year was won by a
gleeful Greta tumber for Sweden with her
postpunk dance Anthem we dared national
holidays were declared music was
commissioned the world declared in
Street parties and festivals and special
sessions of government for the second
time this Century that we had done it
but just because CO2 concentrations had
peaked that did not mean that
temperatures would now start to fall it
would be a few decades before the planet
stabilized its temperature anomaly
before the new anthropogenic climate
would be revealed the question now was
had we done it fast enough had the total
carbon emissions of the past three
centuries produced a world that we and
all other life on Earth could live in in
the early 2060s the answer was unclear
the same year that Peak CO2 was
announced it was discovered that 95% of
all corals had now gone extinct
remaining species were gradually
transferred to captivity to preserve
them for future generations and maybe
for eventual reintroduction to the
oceans on land the situation was little
better after Decades of air and water
pollution habitat loss and
overexploitation the United Nations
environment program announced that the
world had hit rock bottom biodiversity
of the 196 nations in the UN 162 were
estimated to have the same average
biodiversity as a multi-story car park
in some areas notably China and Brazil
species were starting to make a recovery
but this was far from the case
everywhere the continuing loss of
keystone species caused Regional food
webs to go into freefall whether the
global food web was now stable enough to
withand a shock event or indeed further
decline remains an open question in
201100 the following year a quiet
Victory went almost unremarked on
following extensive legislation of ozone
depleting chemicals over the past
Century the ozone layer had been
restored to its pre-industrial
concentration completely closing the
so-called hole over the Antarctic this
legislation also had the effect of
preventing hundreds of gigatons of
carbon being emitted into the atmosphere
unquestionably avoiding multiple
Regional and Global tipping points being
reached an environmental Saga that began
with the search for a safe refrigerant
and nearly causing an unprecedented
atmospheric disaster was finally closed
the same decade the next big technical
demonstration of nuclear fusion became
operational in Japan nearly infinite
clean energy was now just a few decades
away as the plant demonstrated that
Fusion could be maintained and
accounting for energy losses this time
almost precisely as much energy was
produced than was expended the next
technical demonstration would prove that
this could be practical heat waves and
droughts continued large swings in
precipitation changed farming practices
the temperature anomaly continued to
climb though more slowly now as two did
sea levels over the course of the 2060
several island nations became
uninhabitable Vanuatu tuvalu then kabati
and the Marshall Islands all after
several years of desperate adaptation
and many mournful ceremonies abandoned
to the rising tide one exception to this
was the moldes which clung on throughout
the decade in fact the Adams Resort an
entirely floating luxury Hotel was
constructed near Malle in 2061
advertising the last chance to see
holiday of a lifetime if you could pay
for it the ultr rich cantel and staff of
the resort were the last official
residents of the MDES staying far longer
than the indigenous population until
2072 also sinking beneath the waves in
2072 was Exxon Mobile the once Titanic
fossil fuel producer responsible for
delaying action and obscuring climate s
once the most profitable company in the
world shuttered with as much fanfare as
the closure of a regional Airline the
world simply did not need its products
anymore in a twist of fate the Exxon
trademark was eventually bought to
auction by a small Utilities company in
exitor England they of course
exclusively used renewable
electricity the shuttering of Exxon
coincided by chance with a conversation
that had grown in volume over the social
media and neuralink channels of the
early
2070s who was responsible for the
temperature anomaly that still climbed
higher and higher as climate activism
pivoted from examining the future to
examining the present it made sense to
start examining the past especially in
the global South where climate activism
had become especially vocal in the
previous decades and where the climate
crisis was most apparent the question of
responsibility became more of a pressing
talking point as more people were forced
to migrate away from unbearing heat or
from rains too unreliable for
agriculture they quite naturally wanted
to find someone to blame this was of
course the idea of the loss and damage
fund to enable countries in the global
North to pay reparations to those in the
global South but while the mid-century
saw some progress some climate Justice
to many in those regions hardest hit by
the climate crisis it was not enough
this culminated in Acra Ghana and the
controversial IAL Trials of
2073 except trials is something of a
misnomer there were defendants only they
were long dead and Allowed no legal
representation they were oil Executives
presidents Spin Doctors inventors
figures overwhelmingly from Nations
early to industrialize who were to some
degree responsible for the climate
crisis responsible for the loss of over
75 million lives due to pollution due to
the water wars due due to drought and
flood and famine 35 million deaths due
to the delaying tactics of fossil fuel
companies companies responsible for the
loss of as many as 5 million unique
species of plants and animals countries
who developed themselves with cheap
dirty fuels and then pulled the ladder
up on the rest of the world loss and
damage fund or no one of the reasons the
trials took place in Ghana was because
of its long history of exploitation
first by the British and more recently
by the Chinese across Africa the
Investments made by China and
organizations such as the Sino African
nuclear Consortium had increasingly been
met with hostility yes it was very
important to extract lithium and Cobalt
and colan and generate low carbon
electricity Ganan said but it was
important to do so in a way that
respected human life the working and
indeed living conditions of those who
worked in the mines for lithium and ctan
had for far too long been far from
adequate and Chinese multinational
corporations far too reaching in their
use of force as the century rolled on
and Africa Rose in geopolitical
importance the role of China as a
trading partner was thrown into question
and reparations for past actions were
demanded by many nations who had now
been effectively colonized not once but
twice these disputes continue of course
to the present
day by the 2080s for the first time in
human history emissions of all
greenhouse gases were net negative while
CO2 had been net negative for a short
while now largely thanks to aforestation
and bioenergy with carbon capture and
storage methane had stubbornly held on
the problematic Source was agriculture
which had been it must be said something
of an unexpected Victory throughout the
century even when global population
peaked at 10.4 billion people in 2081
food systems were able to just about
feed everyone this was partly due to
improved efficiencies in food Logistics
vastly reducing food waste and partly
due to the global shift to plant-based
diets a key tenant of the international
climate movement apart from being more
calorie efficient on a systems level and
requiring less land the shift also
spectacularly reduced methane emissions
Global agriculture had certainly been
tested droughts and heat waves had led
to Regional crop failures most years and
in the case of India in 2078 a failed
Monsoon and inadequate planning resulted
in the final overthrow of the national
government but with the breaking of seed
monopolies expansion of the United
Nations food program along with shifts
in diets despite fears of fragility the
global food system was able to weather
all but the strongest storms of the 21st
century admittedly at a terrible cost to
the fertility of the world's soils an
issue that remains
in100 but with a final push to produce
me consumption in the 2070s agricultural
methane emissions finally also fell to
net negative and with this the global
temperature anomaly gradually stabilized
the world scientists announced in 2086
was now
1.8 de C warmer than in pre-industrial
times limiting warming to 1 and a half
degrees had slipped out of sight a long
time ago but thanks to the rapid actions
starting in 2014 4 and the breaking of
the fossil fuel economy 2 degre of
warming had been avoided a new climate
had been established it appeared
scientists said with more than a slight
sigh of relief that further tipping
points had been avoided careful
monitoring was still needed but with any
luck the global temperature anomaly
would fall quickly enough over the 22nd
and 23rd centuries to avoid total melt
of the Greenland and Antarctic Ice
Sheets preventing multiple meters of sea
level rise in fact total Oblivion had
also been avoided in the most unlikely
place Coral losses now at over
99% seemed to have stabilized leaving
Corals in critical condition fragments
and dead reefs were scattered all over
the ocean with one Reef remaining in
moderately healthy condition in the
kores it naturally became the most most
protected place in the world's
oceans the world certainly looked very
different from the early Century by the
2090s the vast majority of coral species
were now held in captivity in the face
of Uncertain seasonal snowfall the last
ski resort in the Alps was abandoned in
2091 the Himalayas now being the ski
destination for the world's Rich border
conflicts over water and Arab land
scarcely became news anymore being so
common to culosis was finally eradicated
in 2093 an estimated quarter of a
billion people identified as climate
refugees The Icarus Fusion plant in
Buenos Aries initiated Plasma in 2094
and reached an overall efficiency of
99 some things never change when in 2096
a heat wave in Siberia caused by a huge
Meander in the jet stream combined with
an alino year released a vast quantity
of methane into the atmosphere it was
carefully monitored an enormous network
of global sensors and scientists were
aimed at what was delicately termed the
great burp the World Meteorological
organization accurately forecast its
progress around the world the net
radiative forcing and warming it would
cause an estimated how long it would
delay a return to a pre-industrial
climate a well oiled well-funded and
internationally respected scientific
institution was able to treat what was
once the norm as an interesting oneoff
and then in
2099 an amazing Discovery was made on an
isolated atle in the South Pacific
hundreds of miles from the nearest
inhabited Island a previously
undiscovered pristine coral
reef it was unclear how exactly The Reef
had survived humans altering the climate
and the oceans seemingly this was the
result of some adaptation a new
configuration of interdependent
organisms making their way collectively
through the warm acidified
Waters in 201100 The intergovernmental
panel on climate change released its
special report in it they detailed a
world that had warmed by 1.8 de C whose
Seas were 60 cm higher than they were at
the start of the century that was
missing an ice cap in summer but they
also Det tell the world that would have
been if not for Rapid
decarbonization with four Global tipping
points reached with Europe possibly
thrown back into the Ice Age with
hundreds of millions displaced or
deceased due to continued use of fossil
fuels propped up by government subsidies
and it detailed the environmental
challenges that would define The Next
Century after all history does not stop
here there will be a world beyond the
year 2100 100 and the actions we take
now will shape the century to come we
have demonstrated in the past that we
can overcome immense challenges
environmental and otherwise but it will
require concerted effort and courage yes
from individuals making informed choices
but more so from government at Urban
National and international levels the
challenge may be great but so is our
capacity for change a statement that is
as true today as it was a century
ago this video was a synoptic
retrospective from 2100 due to its broad
scope it could not be deep with details
and O to the Future being so difficult
to predict could not hope to be accurate
either regardless I hope that it is
instructive that it shows a path
forwards in different sectors that not
all decision made this Century will be
the right ones and that key decisions
are made by the public not by
individuals and also that waiting until
2044 isn't necessary it also would not
have been possible without the
contributions of over 2 dozen
individuals to present a possible
plausible even if not likely version of
the 21st century I spoke to over two
dozen experts in energy and economics
geopolitics and activism transport and
media and of course weather and climate
some of their names are on screen right
now a key collaborator who helped shape
a realistic path for the climate this
century was Professor Dan Mitchell of
the University of Bristol together we
wrote the key bullet points of how the
climate could change this Century of
course however those bullet points had
to become a story to see how our
discussion became a story and how things
might have gone a little differently you
can watch Professor Mitchell and I in
conversation in a special video on
nebula nebula is home to some of the
most original thought-provoking
educational video content on the
Internet it's a platform built by
creators including myself that allows us
to post what we think is important and
not worry about constraints like
pleasing advertisers or playing to the
YouTube algorithm it's home to original
shows like modern conflicts the
logistics of du list mansion and China
actually that you can't find anywhere
else but also features early releases of
full videos from all creators that you
would otherwise watch later on YouTube
and all these videos are entirely ad
free nebula isn't trying to compete with
YouTube think of it more like the
Netflix of educational entertaining
video some of those videos like my
discussion of the 21st century with
Professor Mitchell are one-offs While
others are part of ongoing series all
are available as part of a subscription
which is then split between the creators
that you watch it's a business model
that we creators far prefer and is a far
better way of supporting our work and
helping us make more videos than
watching on our YouTube channels nebula
also offers classes including my own
class in scientific film making and
podcasts including how to make a science
video in which myself and Sophie Ward
interview top creators about their video
making process if you would like to see
behind the scenes of this video learn
how to make videos like it yourself and
enjoy a superior ad free viewing
experience able to download videos to
your device and watch later and many
other advantages then head to go.
nebula.com membership a one-off payment
of $300 and you get nebula for as long
as both you and we exist this is our way
of raising capital for a bunch of huge
Creator Le projects that we're hoping
hoping to produce next year I can't tell
you what they are but they're very
ambitious and we'd love to get the
capital for them from our audience
rather than outside investors you can
make that possible and in return get
lifetime access to nebula and never have
to worry about managing your
subscription again that's go.
nebula.jpg so much for watching this
video this has been an intensely
personal project for me the last video
of mine my dad ever watched was the
previous installment in this series The
Decade we lost Earth that video painted
Humanity at its worst I wanted this next
episode to be a hopeful one of a future
that he will never see but I think
represents Humanity as he believed it
could be I wanted him to know that a
happy ending does exist as I previously
stated thanks musco to my many
collaborators on this project but also
to my many patrons who directly support
me every month and allow me to make
ambitious expensive projects like this
one patrons get access to exclusive
behind the- scenes content every month
vote for a video topic a month and in
the case of executive producer patrons
get their names immortalized in videos
if you would like to join them please go
to
Linked In the description please do
share this video with your friends and
family as a possible path through this
coming Century if you enjoyed it please
do also give it a like and let me know
your thoughts in the comments thank you
again for watching and I'll see you in
the next one